[Musique]
la famille Simard est à l'image des
bleuets qu'elle cultive si CCRI dans
cette bleuetière durant Saint-Eusèbe à
Saint-Félicien 4 générations sont à
l'oeuvre dans les champs létés le doyen
du groupe c'est Raphaël Simard rien de
la rate pas même si 97 ans
[Musique]
en forêt sur les terres de son
grand-père au peigne quatre générations
ont possédé la bleue et tiercement et
fils depuis 1990 c'est son garçon qui
veille sur cet héritage
[Musique]
avec mon grand-père
pour venir cueillir ici mais dans ce
temps-là me promener qu'une famille on a
promis
aujourd'hui la bleue esther est
productive mais c'est le faut toujours
un cœur solide pour gérer les
soubresauts de dames nature Raphaël
Simard à cette fille un garçon et
plusieurs petits-enfants et arrière
petits enfants les moments en famille
ont donc de quoi adoucir les jours
difficiles et cette attachement mutuelle
se traduit jusque dans les noms donnés
aux chemins de la blueysière
[Musique]
pour moi là
c'est un moment que je peux travailler
avec mon père de voir mon grand-père
aussi ramasser puis être heureux parce
que
il est heureux c'est ça sa période de
l'année où il y ait le plus heureux puis
ça c'est plaisant de le voir comme ça ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu mais
normalement un grand papa c'est ça c'est
quand je suis content
il est proche de Raphaël Simard
s'habille qu'il ne sera pas éternel il
continue dans magasiner les souvenirs
sur ses terres qui seront cédés à la
prochaine génération le doyen des lieux
lui compte cueillir tant qu'il le pourra
être intéressant
[Musique]